it's been just over two years since MP
Joe Cox was murdered in broad daylight
in her constituency by a far-right
extremist in that short time the
far-right virus has entered the
bloodstream of the body politic to be an
anti-immigrant anti-muslim nativist
party is the new normal and it's
contagious a quarter of voters in this
country would back such a party leaders
like Russia's Putin the Philippines
duterte turkeys are doin and not
dictators says a columnist in The Times
newspaper they are strong men are timid
politicians should copy as like
Mussolini at least two wrong men get
things done like make their trains run
on time I don't know about you but all
this terrifies me internationalism not
nationalism since the end of the second
world war has given us golden eggs in
the shape of longer safer happier more
comfortable lives we must not allow the
far-right narrative to become normalized
otherwise populism will turn into a
suicide cult killing off the Golden
Goose of liberal democratic capitalism
[Music]
it yes the rise of the far-right worries
me but I think I know what the reason
for it is and I think it could be
stopped in a bit but I think you're
wrong to say that people don't people
want to be internationalist I think
increasingly I didn't say people want to
be nationalists I said international
show has can I think over 75 years
people and grave their own national
identity I think people want to run
their own people we all see stats wait
carry on but well if you let me carry on
I will both of you interrupting I'm
trying to come back let me let me wants
to be let me I didn't say that I said I
think people are turning away from
internationalism and turning to wanting
to run their own country they want to
run their they work they want to run
their own societies they want to be
updated too
by their own histories and traditions
traditions that the EU knows nothing
about and cares even less about and and
the EU has tried to crush all of that by
making the one voice the one state the
one law and I and I think Rachel you
know look around you look at you look
where it's happening it's happening in
Germany where where Angela let me just
let me speak for a second then you can
all come in Angela Merkel in Germany
she's hanging to power by a thread
because of what because of her policy on
immigration in in the Netherlands it's
the same thing in France is our gaining
tracks okay I want to say one more thing
and they're like it then I'll then I'll
go
most people currently vote for the
far-right out of anger and frustration
that not out of conviction and I believe
I truly believe that is the case at the
moment but I think unless governments
start listening to the people of their
own country the referendum result in
this country was the direct result of
the political and cultural elites
ignoring the fears of the people the
voice of concerned as using this as a
wedge is very if their nastiness into
the PRC but it can be stopped if
government start listening to people to
ordinary people people out there listen
to them
to that yeah I got point on listening I
think that the let's have a look at some
figures on you kit because twelve point
six percent of the vote in 2015 is what
they got and then there was a bit of
listening done Carol and their vote
share went down to two percent in 2017 I
think there are ways hi I am for mostly
infamous because I never hear the end of
it suggested a Nigel Farrar should be
given a peerage and my intention was to
put him in our Lord's the reason why
June is that when you put someone in the
House of Lords they're officially deemed
retired and they do nothing but gather
cobwebs and they're out from the
political debate and they can no longer
rail against new rules don't apply where
Nigel fried was apparently not the
decline of your ships though 38% will
vote for a new right wing party
committed to for exigent I think 24%
would vote for an exclusive because
polite
listening to the people they're not
listening you know now we have we have a
bunch of still the political and control
ease trying to overturn the bogus
Democratic decision this country's ever
made the government is not listening to
people if I may but like can I just say
what the Steve Bannon who used to run
the far-right bright very frightening is
now setting up a sort of abba style suit
what he calls supergroup in brussels -
he calls it the mom or gate his
extremist anti-immigrant rhetoric let's
have a look listen to what Steve Brannon
is saying let them call you racist let's
see let's see what's up if Isis let them
call you son of opes man I suppose I
please enough let them call you nativist
let's see fully Zeppelin ATVs to wear it
as a badge of honor
Bhati to command badge donor because
every day we get stronger and they get
weaker to hear this in 2018 supergroup
this is here we go again back to let you
know I was just gonna say when I came in
earlier that so I was gonna move to
Steve Patton because of course he was
interviewed LBC by Nigel Faraj and I
thankfully was on immediately afterwards
and had the chance to respond I listened
to everything he said and what he
believes in it is honestly fascistic and
I use that term rarely and here I think
it applies he believes in this theory
that he admitted on the interview called
the fourth turning he believes history
turns out four crucial points the fourth
turning is violence and he's actively a
bit like you know communist agitators
except he's the other end of the
spectrum he's actively agitating for
that because he believes only through
that violence can productive change
emerged and he believes that the last
time there's Apple as world war two
these people are preparing for
existential conflict and I'm very very
worried I don't think it'll happen I
think I think it's not dangerous yet I
think it could become dangerous if
people don't start listening Merkel is
necessary to start registering for
kosher meat but you know but but the
far-right can only exist because it taps
into people's anger and frustration if
people were less less frustrated and
angry at their governments they wouldn't
be able to survive they won't have the
but what we could end up with because I
I think Steve Bannon and
this sort of right movement I think they
realized that they're not going to be
able to take over nations in the way
that you you're suggesting he is going
country to country and stirring up
hatred in all of these extreme groups
and as a way they are then connected
that way but they've always existed
tension they've always existed trying to
do is to create fear and almost believe
order but the only shows yes do you
think that he should be allowed to go
around fermenting this kind of anti race
sorry naughty race I can't get it right
today crazy racist sentiments across
Europe do you think that's just parks
even for a bit but I do think that for a
very long time
anybody who has dared to have a concern
about uncontrolled immigration has been
deemed racist and xenophobic and they
have had their perfectly legitimate
concerns suppressed and and stopped and
dismissed when you suppress a perfectly
legitimate concern then you do you
naturally create an environment where
you start off over here going well
actually my entire city is
unrecognizable from the one that I've
lived in my entire life but I can't talk
about that
then over here comes somebody talking
about this albeit in a much more extreme
voice than your constable with you start
off by going class a bit more but then
you start kind of gradually going well
actually he or she absolutely yeah where
it should end you you need to have a
situation where you are allowing people
to voice over a legitimate cause you
know you shouldn't be allowing people to
go oh I've you're Jewish let's have you
know whatever or if you're Muslim let's
have that's not a legitimate concern but
if what you're saying is you know what
my entire city is completely different
there is you keep trying just elope but
actually actually yeah it is not legit
I said there you actually mentioned it's
absolutely not legitimate to be ante
all Muslims ante all Jewish people ante
all immigrants we have even got time to
talk about what's going on the Labor
Party how my point by talking about
anti-semitism because you know when you
talk about people are anti-immigrant
anti-muslim I actually don't think
that's the situation I think a lot of
people are concerned by uncontrolled
immigration and the facts and the impact
set on their life I think people are
concerned I don't think it's completely
dissociated from what's going I just
want to say that everything you've
described sounds to me like a process of
radicalization it happened the same
thing happened with Muslims after it was
ended we've got to be aware of it but it
doesn't excuse people turning to people
like Steve Allen Gordon Brown told them
yeah I know that but I'm saying that
everyone has grievances as grievance is
it doesn't justify resorting to
extremism